we need to change the way we think about
the climate challenge
because things are different this time
we need to stop thinking about it just
as a problem which it obviously is
and start thinking about it as an
opportunity which will motivate us to
solve it
i'm a venture investor i invest in early
stage companies and technologies
and i see tremendous opportunities in
solving climate change
that said we've been here before and
it's different this time
we can reduce net emissions to zero
and that was not obvious even just 10
years ago
why do i think it's different
because we have cheaper inputs we have
better technologies we have better
policies we have
a better
sense of urgency and most important of
all we have even better people working
on it
i'm from silicon valley and you can
laugh or shrug if you think that the
valley is more part of the problem than
part of the solution
but consider this
to succeed if we want to succeed we have
to act at such a truly massive scale
we need the best investors and
entrepreneurs on our team
and it's a fact that some 15 years ago a
bunch of us started working on
technologies and companies that could
help solve climate change
and we had some successes
in
solar and in wind in electric vehicles
and transportation
but
accelerated by the great recession of
2008
climate tech cleantech came to be seen
as a string of investment failures
i don't think we failed
we were a little bit early and a little
bit naive
we didn't have all those building blocks
not enough of us
knew that solving climate change was the
greatest business opportunity of our
generation
and
we were a little bit naive we
underestimated how hard it was going to
be to disrupt entrenched companies and
industries that did not want to change
but now
so many more people are invested in
solving it
we have those building blocks
and we have even more people working on
it that's why i'm so optimistic and
excited why it's different this time
let me detail a few
first we have cheaper inputs
the biggest input in our economy and the
dominant cost is energy
until now the dominant source of energy
is fossils coal
oil gas
climate change is caused by burning
fossil fuels
until recent but now
prompted by a incredible decline in cost
solar and wind are the cheapest forms of
electricity most places on the planet
until recently while we knew that
fossils were the source of the problem
we had no alternatives
stopping fossils would have meant
stopping the economy
alternatives now exist
two
we have better technologies
consider
lithium-ion batteries and how they
enabled the electric vehicle of
revolution those batteries are now being
applied towards other applications and
other opportunities
we have better computers and new ways of
using them
machine learning and artificial
intelligence applied to big data sets
and it enables us to explore and develop
new materials it enables us to
reduce energy needs and it enables us to
solve problems in previously
unimaginable ways
some as simple as software that
companies use to
optimize delivery routes we use less
fuel to get stuff places
the bioeconomy has crispr and other gene
editing tools those can be used to help
plants like wheat corn rice soy grow
with less inputs less water less
fertilizer
massive opportunities
and we are in the early stages of
developing equipment that can suck
carbon dioxide out of the air
with the promise of one day reversing
some of the pollution we've been pouring
into our atmosphere for the past two
hundred years
three
we have and are developing better
materials
the streets we walk on the buildings we
work on work in they're made of concrete
and steel
combined those two contribute over 15
percent of global emissions
now we can start making buildings up to
20 stories or more high without any
steel or concrete their structure is
made of laminated mass timber which
actually sequesters carbon
and at the same time we're developing
ways of making steel and concrete
without emissions
fourth
climate is now sexy elegant and chic
electric vehicles were invented in the
1880s as recently as the 1990s though
they were clunky and ugly you couldn't
go much more than 50 miles on a single
charge
now
we have
safe affordable fun to drive sexy
electric vehicles i think in five years
we're going to be surprised we'll be
shocked if people want to buy a gasoline
version
or consider solar panels not too long
ago many communities banned them from
being installed on their roofs for fear
that they would uglify the neighborhood
now they look like roofs they're a
status symbol you have to have them
other panels are used to power not just
homes but companies and factories
messaging matters
fifth there is so much more money being
directed towards zero emissions
investments
solving these problems building these
companies takes hard work and
entrepreneurs and it takes money until
not so long ago there weren't many
people willing to invest in the riskiest
technologies
now we have dedicated pools of capital
focused across climate from early stage
technologies and companies to
later stage development and massive
utility scale projects that require
billions of dollars which actually
encourages more capital to come in
and is a virtual cycle
each of these examples this is not an
exhaustive list but each of these
examples are real
real opportunities that are in
development
we also have better policies governments
are
making plans that make them good
partners and customers for entrepreneurs
we know so much more about climate and
justice we have real demand from the
public to solve it
we have engineers and scientists and
investors working around the planet on
these problems
put these things together and a clear
picture emerges a realistic pathway
towards a clean future for
these things have another characteristic
they are combinatorial one accelerates
the other one
propels the next forward
for instance
with cheap green electricity we will
soon have cheap green hydrogen
green hydrogen can be used to power
homes and factories it can be used to
make nitro make fertilizer or it can be
used to make steel without emissions
tremendous opportunities
we're developing storage systems and
batteries that are the missing link to
make wind and solar firm and
dispatchable real alternatives to
fossils
and
mark my words the combination of evs and
electric trains remote sensors and big
data analytics it's going to
revolutionize how we move people and
goods around the planet
of course we still have a lot to do
we have to develop the solutions we have
and we have to
develop and invent some for some to
solve some wickedly hard problems many
of which i've mentioned already
for instance how do we grow healthy food
without emissions
while protecting and restoring nature
how do we
construct our buildings and fly
airplanes without emissions
how do we
recycle minerals instead of mining for
new and how do we make chemicals without
drilling for oil and gas
how do we make steel without emissions
and concrete that absorbs carbon dioxide
at scale
and how do we all
especially big emitters like
multinational corporations
track and report our emissions because
you cannot manage what you don't measure
we need good
reliable transparent carbon accounting
another massive opportunity developing
carbon accounting and reporting software
now
so many people
understand the urgency of the situation
we understand that new and now go hand
in hand we can't sit around waiting for
a solution we need to get out and
develop the ones we have while we invent
the ones we don't have yet
and none of this happens without
passionate people and that's why i'm so
excited so optimistic
i see it everywhere
from young people in the united states
who refuse to work for a company that
isn't committed to a clean future
to engineers in africa developing the
infrastructure the water and the
electricity that continent needs but
doing so sustainably and this is also
combinatorial great people attract more
great people which catalyzes more money
brings in even more great people it's a
virtuous cycle
having worked the the key factor in any
effort in any enterprise the key factor
in that success is the people and having
worked in innovation almost all my adult
life
i can honestly say that the people i
work with every day are
you are
the solution
we are different this time and that's
why it's different this time and we will
succeed
thank you
you